mercredi vers 12h30 marie-eve laplante a
cru qu'elle allait mourir avec sa fille
de 8 mois
oui oui j'avais les mains qui
tremblaient j'avais les yeux dans l'eau
pis mais c'est un choc
infernal on entend le bruit justement
puis le poids de contrôle
ça y est c'est fini c'est quelqu'un qui
voit arriver dans un mois
la mère de famille circulait sur
l'autoroute 15 en direction sud
lorsque le vent s'est levé soudainement
créant un mur blanc comme en témoigne
cette vidéo tournée par un autre
automobiliste
j'ai mis mes car cela s'avéra lanceur
vraiment pas beau donc j'ai vraiment
ralenti ma vitesse créé l'oeuvre
on voyait rien marie-eve la plante
réussi à immobiliser son véhicule sans
heurter ceux qui se trouvent devant elle
mais elle regarde derrière elle c'est la
panique
j'ai l'enfant est venu plusieurs
voyaient dans mon rétroviseur nantes les
autos sans voix que je savais qu'elle
bbp derrière - je mets mon dieu sauvez
mon bébé la famille sa fille s'en
sortent indemnes
mercredi le ministre des transports
affirmait que ce tronçon de l'a 15
n'était pas dangereux des habitués de
cette autoroute l'ont contredit
j'arrivais dans le fond de passé par
l'opie de santé vraiment envie que le
passé cette zone là est souvent souvent
comme ça quand tu vas voir des rafales
de vent qui se lève subitement françois
bonnardel s'est finalement ravisé jeudi
matin et cherche des solutions
jai materner les automobilistes mais
encore une fois à nos signalisation pour
les avertir bourrasques conditions
dangereuses s'il faut le faire comme on
le fait sur l'a40 surtout qu'à ramallah
janet dépasser aussi de le faire dès cet
été
il y a déjà un panneau dans ce secteur
est d'ailleurs un porte parole du mtq a
confirmé par téléphone que les feux
clignotants étaient activées avant le
carambolage
marie-eve la plante se remet de ses
émotions suis vraiment chanceuse le
policier lui toi que j'avais fait elle
considère qu'elle a déjà remporté le
gros lot ici pas les michael abeilles ne
fera du canada
saint-constant